foreign
how do we find balance and this is a
global dratia question here how do we
find balance
between achievement on a grand scale and
here's what I mean you have accomplished
many wonderful things as I as I
embarrass myself in the intro here you
have done so much productivity wise and
you've presented it to the world in a
way that helps all these people
and I want my buddy Peter to have a
great marriage and like his kids want to
come home when they graduate college and
want to come hang out
at what point how do you find that
balance I feel like the The Narrative is
one of two ways one we get one narrative
which is
crush it and kill it and go and go and
go and go and go and if you have a
feeling and if you get tired it's
because you're weak and you seem to suck
it up and the other feel the other path
is
the seven million men who just said dude
I'm out of the workforce I'm out of here
or quiet quitting or sitting at home or
just like you mentioned earlier I just
feel so disempowered I man I'm I'm out
there has to be a new third way here to
both
achieve things do well contribute to
society and not melt yourself in the
process but if I look back on those who
have really made a mark on society
they left awake behind him and I don't
know how to find that balance
and this is a macro this is this is Dr
Atia a global voice on you know
best-selling author but it's also
Tim the Boy Scout leader who's got two
kids right
yeah I mean I I I don't
I guess I can only speak to this from my
experience I I certainly felt the
need to uh as the way I described it
when I was
kind of younger and my wife will talk
about this if
um you know the way I would talk about
it to her when we first got married is I
wanted to build a skyscraper and I just
said look if you go into
if you if you look out of the world it's
mostly just townhouses and there's only
a few skyscrapers out there and there's
there's people who have done
unbelievable exceptional things that
have stood out and I want to be one of
those I want to build this skyscraper
and I just was adamant about that I had
to do this I had to build a skyscraper
and
um
there's just there's just no question in
my mind now where that was coming from
and how unhealthy that was and that's
kind of the irony of it is I think a lot
of people who do build skyscrapers
whether it means through some enormous
financial success or even through
something more productive right like you
know literally creating a technology
that is you know valuable
um
a lot of times there's probably a void
that's being filled there and and while
the world may benefit from what they've
done it might not necessarily be
um ultimately filling that void
I I can only say that today
um I first of all I realize how kind of
grandiose that aspiration is and and
that's not surprising it's congruent and
consistent with everything that I now
know about myself and my past and it's
not an accident that I would
find myself in a very grandiose position
as the defense mechanism
I also realized that statistically
the probability that any one of us
really matter cosmically is is pretty
much zero right so like we just have to
be honest and think about this which is
you know even when you think about the
most significant people dying it it just
it
you know to borrow that phrase bending
the Ark of the universe I'm not sure who
first used that expression very few
people bend the Ark of the universe and
I'm much happier today not trying to
build a skyscraper and not trying to
bend the Ark of the universe because
first of all I just know it's it wasn't
making me any happier being in pursuit
of it two if I'm going to be brutally
honest I wasn't going to do it
and three it's allowing me to optimize
more for something that I think is more
valuable which is the you know time I
have with the people who matter most to
me
and
I don't think I have this figured out
like I I mean I'm also I'm clearly
trying to be the guy in the middle I'm
not retiring I'm not saying I'm not
going to work I'm not
I'm not working 40 hours a week right
you know I'm not taking weekends off to
do
you know to not work I mean I'm still
I'm still working probably harder than I
would even like to work but
[Music]
um
it's just it's just different it doesn't
feel like I'm trying to change the world
um and
I I think my priorities have really
shifted and
um but I think I'll always still
struggle with you know just as a just as
a
a former alcoholic is probably always
going to have to be on guard against you
know having another drink I think a
former workaholic is always going to
have to be on guard when it comes to
making choices that very you know
quickly can put you back into
destructive habits
the way I've tried to make peace with it
is
I need people I got two little kids I
need people out there solving some of
these big complex issues at the local
level and at the national level the
global level
I want people out there really going for
it and I've had to look in the mirror
and say you can go for it
but that call from Dad's not coming
that that that certificate's not going
to come in the mail that says hey I'm
I'm really proud of it it's not going to
come right it's not going to solve me
and that may be the ultimate skyscraper
I wanted to build right
um I want to do all this and achieve all
of this because then it it then then I
finally sew up that hole inside and it
just
I don't know so I I guess I I want
people to achieve I just wanted to know
that it's not going to heal you you got
to do that work somewhere else
yeah and I I think that you know
building off what you're saying I mean I
think a bigger skyscraper for me is
after I'm dead like nobody remembers me
other than my kids and my grandkids and
my friends like that that's to me that's
a legacy worth having
um not
the 10 years after I'm dead someone's
writing an article about me like it I
that just doesn't mean anything zero
yeah um yeah so so so knowing that after
my kids go to college they actually want
to come home knowing that after my kids
get married they actually want to be
near us they want to you know they want
to call me when they have a problem I
mean those are things that are going to
matter far more to me than
any and anything else I'm doing